- [Narrator] These are sea turtle eggs,
and there are two ways this
situation can play out.
There's either:
♫ Hallelujah
Or there's:
(dramatic orchestral music)
So, how can we make sure this:
♫ Hallelujah
doesn't end up like this?
(dramatic orchestral music)
Well, take a look again.
These aren't your
ordinary sea turtle eggs.
These eggs could one day take down
an entire poaching network.
The story of these eggs
starts in Ann Arbor, Michigan.
- Hi, I'm Kim Williams-Guillen,
and I am a conservation ecologist.
- [Narrator] Kim does research
on a wide variety of animals,
but we're here to talk about endangered
and threatened sea turtles.
- With sea turtles in Central America,
there's an issue of poaching of the nests
for consumption of the eggs.
- [Narrator] And so,
her team has developed
a unique solution to
gather more information
about the poaching trade:
fake eggs with GPS trackers.
- We can hide these fake turtle
eggs in sea turtle nests.
Our hope is that these
eggs will get poached along
with the others and transmit
information on their locations.
Where is it that they go after
they're taken from the beach?
- [Narrator] But for this to work,
the fake eggs have to be convincing.
- They have to have the right feel
because sea turtle eggs are kind of
a little soft and squishy.
They're not like chicken eggs.
We've been using a 3D printer
and a kind of flexible plastic,
but they still don't look quite right.
- [Narrator] And this
is when our story moves
to Los Angeles.
- Hello, I'm Lauren.
- [Narrator] And Lauren
works in Hollywood.
- My day-to-day job is I work
on set as a makeup artist,
which could be beauty makeup, prosthetics,
creature design, wigs, blood.
- [Narrator] So it made sense for Lauren
to help Kim make fake eggs.
- We needed these eggs to look
realistic, to feel realistic,
and so that's kind of where I've come in.
It was like the best way that
I could use my skills making prosthetics,
but to actually like help
a whole species of turtles.
It's like, it’s a dream job.
- [Narrator] After months of revisions,
it's time to put these eggs
to the test in Costa Rica.
- Hi again.
- [Narrator] You remember Kim.
She's here to deploy the eggs herself
on a protected conservation area.
- This is a place that's very special
because it's a very
important nesting site.
Tonight, a sea turtle will
come and I can test out putting
the false sea turtle eggs in the nest.
- [Narrator] Not only will
this project provide Kim's team
with valuable information on poaching,
she and Lauren hope it will
inspire others as well.
- Wildlife poaching can be abstract
or too depressing to even think about.
Something about this project kind
of captures people's attention.
Here's this very simple,
unique solution that,
I think, then serves
as a jumping off point
for people's imaginations to
learn more about this trade.
- All of us working on this
project are just doing it
in our weird little nooks
and wherever we can,
and it just goes to show
there's so many little ways
that everyone can help.
You don't have to be
making fake turtle eggs
to make a difference.
You can make a difference in your own way.